[Music]
we watched good luck charlie unde is
knee channels so many times that we
finally stopped being distracted by the
story and thoughts and mistakes we are
here today to show you what we found in
case you didn't notice it before stay
tuned until the end to see all the
mistakes you missed in the TV movie good
luck charlie it's Christmas if you love
good luck charlie as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you ten mistakes in good luck
charlie you didn't notice the magic word
we looked for mistakes in the first
season but we couldn't find any or maybe
that's because the show was so good that
we were too distracted by the story to
pay attention to what was really
happening it is in the fifth episode of
the second season Duncan versus Duncan
that we finally found a little mistake
in this episode the parents wanted to
spend the night at the hotel because it
was free this is why the kids and even
Teddy wanted to have a party
unfortunately their parents got into a
little fight so they didn't want to go
on a date anymore
they would be staying home and there is
no way the kids could have a party if
they were there Teddy and PJ did try to
make their parents apologize but it did
not work this is why they had to try
something else
they tricked Charlie into saying that
she was sad because the parents were
fighting Teddy told her to work her
magic so they could have a party then
the kids started repeating the word
party instead of saying her lines but we
think that the actress said the word a
little too loud to remind the girl
playing her little sister that this is
the word that she would have to say
thanks for your help bridgit mendler but
we clearly saw it coming
hey guys we wanted to give a huge shout
out to our new friends super kids
honestly these kids are so much fun to
watch so we click on the link in the
description to check out their videos
they're new to YouTube so please give
them a warm welcome
by subscribing to their Channel
[Music]
the water bottle we had to wait a whole
other season before we could see another
mistake and good luck charlie
but we can't complain because watching
this sitcom is not really a difficult
job we saw another mistake in the second
episode of the third season
bad luck Teddy in the first scene amy
entered the room and asked Gabe if he
thought that she was smoking for a
pregnant woman unfortunately for her the
son thought that silence was the best
answer she was striking a pose when we
noticed a little mistake that stole our
attention when she entered the room amy
was holding the water bottle in her left
hand but when we looked at it from
another angle she was holding it in her
right hand that's where it stayed for
the rest of the scene as she didn't have
the time to move before we looked at her
from another angle we think that there
is only one way we can explain this
the actress made a mistake when she was
filming this scene because she didn't do
the same thing in all the different
takes Amy might not be perfect but we
can say that her son Gabe is that was
the episode when he tried to be the best
child in the world because he thought
that his parents wanted to send him to
military school this time we didn't see
a lot of mistakes in the sitcom
so it was hard to believe that there was
another one in the same episode but we
saw it shortly after the first one this
time Charlie was getting a haircut at a
hair salon for kids it was a really nice
place where kids can sit in cars or on
animals while they are getting a haircut
PJ wanted to be the next one to sit in
the car but his father Bob had to tell
him that the manager talked to him about
this they thought that PJ was now a
little too old to get a haircut at this
place Bob had to tell him that if he is
old enough to vote he is old enough to
go to a real barber shop PJ was upset
because barbershops don't give out
stickers and lollipops but he changed
his mind when he noticed a really cute
female barber she is the reason why you
were probably too distracted to see one
little mistake in this scene but if you
look in the background you can clearly
see the neon sign reading barber shop
but the sign is facing the inside of the
building which makes it impossible for
people to read it when they are outside
even if it is in the window the foot the
Christmas special of the third season
gave us a little gift another mistake in
a Duncan Christmas Amy wanted to perform
deck the halls at the annual Duncan
Christmas Eve talent show she was ready
for competition as she told the kids
that they were brave to sing on the same
night
she does however as soon as Amy saw
Bob's mom Linda we could see that she
was not too confident anymore it just
got worse when we learned that Linda
wanted to sing deck the halls at the
Duncan Christmas Eve talent show that's
not the kind of competition amy was
ready to face the two women first wanted
to do an impression of another family
member and we knew that things were not
going to turn out well but then they
decided to stop fighting and sing as a
duet so we had some hope they started
fighting again to see who would get the
most attention
Linda even intentionally stepped on
Amy's foot however if you watch the
scene once again you'll notice that the
actress didn't do it for real Amy just
pretended that she was hurt when she
heard the noise we understand that the
actors playing grandma wanted to be
polite but it just totally looks weird
when we watch it on TV anyway most of us
were too distracted to see this so we'll
forgive that little mistake the attic
who knew that a mistake would be coming
once again in the following episode all
fall down there are so few mistakes that
it is hard to see them but we know that
it was there the episode started with
the whole family stuck in a hotel room
and they were not on vacation this was
when we had the chance to see what
happened one week earlier as soon as Bob
showed the Brazilian termites that he
found at work we knew what was going to
happen in this episode but that was not
a reason not to watch it Gabe wasn't
happy in this episode because he had to
share a room with Toby this is why PJ
found him sleeping in the basement then
he tried to move his room to the living
room but Amy didn't agree with that then
he tried the laundry room until he
realized that it was not really
comfortable and there was too much noise
in the garage and outside of the house
wasn't good either this was when PJ
talked about the Attic and Gabe said
that he didn't even know that they had
an attic however if you ever listen to
Charlie shakes it up you know that came
dead here about the Attic before because
Amy asked him to clean it how can you
forget about an entire room in their
house the pencil another mistake was
coming in the next episode duncan dream
house but we had to wait for another
season in the first episode of the
fourth season duncan dream house the
family was forced to stay in a hotel
room while their house devoured by
termites was being fixed they didn't
only have to stay together in the same
room but they also had to save money to
fix the house which made things much
more complicated but Bob and Amy were
really happy to hear that it meant that
they would get the chance to build their
dream
dream house Bob had a ton of ideas and
this is why he drew a sketch and showed
it to the whole family but if they
really looked at what he was doing they
would have noticed that there were many
mistakes in that scene bob was first
holding a black sharpie but then it
disappeared and he was holding a yellow
mechanical pencil we saw this Sharpie
once again and then it was back to the
yellow mechanical pencil the actor
probably used different pencils in two
different takes and it clearly showed
after editing but how did he lose his
sharpie and decided to pick another
random pencil that didn't look the same
at all he probably thought that we
wouldn't notice but we certainly did the
plane the sitcom was so good that we
couldn't find any other mistake but we
were really happy to watch the TV movie
good luck charlie it's Christmas and
find a lot of other movie mistakes but
we never thought that the first line of
the movie would be just plain wrong it
just couldn't start in a worse way Teddy
said that the flight to Palm Springs
with the Charlie's first time on a plane
but those who watch the whole sitcom
knew that it didn't make sense at all
that's because the little Charlie took
the plane not only once but twice and
Charlie shakes it up Charlie Teddy and
Amy flew to Chicago to visit their rich
great aunt Nellie and ended up in the
studio of shake it up Chicago in Sun
show part one the whole family also took
a plane to Hawaii for Bob and Amy's 20th
wedding anniversary
maybe the screenwriters thought that it
was cute to say that Charlie never went
on a plane before but the camp maker
lived three first times it was time for
them to find another joke no matter what
we knew that a lot of other interesting
things are going to happen on this trip
so we can forgive this little mistake
and it just makes us want to pay even
more attention to the film in case we
see something else the airport the
family said since the beginning of the
movie that they were going on vacation
this is why we quickly saw them at the
airport if you ever watched good luck
charlie you probably understood that it
was filmed in a studio to make things a
little bit more realistic someone filmed
real locations from outside then added
them before the scenes so we can clearly
understand where the characters are this
time the Duncan family was going to the
Denver Airport it couldn't be clearer as
Denver International Airport was even
written on this
but if you have ever been to the Denver
Airport you probably noticed the pretty
distinct roof to represent the Rockies
however when the Duncan's were leaving
Denver the city where they live we
noticed that it didn't look like that at
all
many people noticed that what they
filmed was actually the Reagan Airport
in DC as the Washington Monument was
visible in the background maybe it was
easier for them to film this Airport but
anyone who cared about facts knows that
the family probably wouldn't travel that
far to go to an airport when there is
one where they live anyway when we see
Denver International Airport on the
screen with the Reagan Airport in DC we
know that this was nothing but a big
mistake how can they not even notice in
which city they were filming this the
wipers Teddy wanted to have the chance
to go on vacation with her best friend
while Amy wanted to protect her daughter
this is why they both missed the plane
and how to find another way to go to
Palm Springs they thought that going
there by bus would be the best idea but
they quickly regretted it however this
is not the only mistake that they made
Amy got sick and they were kicked out
off the bus and then another mistake
happened Teddy and Amy had to buy an old
car and they were driving at night we
knew that things were just going to get
worse
Teddy turn on the windshield wipers and
the one on Amy's side just blew off it
was really funny so this is certainly
something that we remembered but then
the next morning Amy and Teddy woke up
in the diner parking lot if you looked
at the windshield you could see that
both wipers were back on the car they
probably didn't have time to fix it
during all their crazy adventure this is
why we think that filmmakers just didn't
want to waste their time with that joke
and made sure that everything was back
to normal shortly after but we think
that it would have been even more fun if
the wiper was not there anymore the next
morning the camera anyone who watched
even just one episode of the sitcom good
luck Charlie knows that Teddy loves
filming her little family after all the
whole point of the TV series is seeing
Teddy filming what happens in their
crazy everyday life so her little sister
will have the chance to watch these
videos when she grows up but this time
we think that Teddy did a little
something wrong the family finally found
a way to spend Christmas together and
they wanted to celebrate the big moment
that their mom was waiting for when
Teddy was filming Charlie putting the
star on the Christmas tree we could see
her through the cameras
it made us feel like we were the ones
filming this scene teddy quickly put
away the camera because after all she
can't spend the whole movie just telling
stories we want to see just what
happened that day but then we could see
Charlie through the cameras I once again
even though Teddy wasn't filming her
anymore
we do agree that it looked good but we
have to say that it just didn't make
sense did you notice any other mistakes
and good luck charlie don't be shy to
tell us what you saw in the comments
section down below we love to hear what
you think and that's it for ten mistakes
and good luck charlie you didn't notice
for more stories like this make sure you
watch dark secrets good luck charlie
tried to hide thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]